>>> THIS MORNING, NEW POLICE
BODY CAM VIDEO REVEALS A TEXAS
STATE TROOPER WAS ON THE SCENE
OF THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
SHOOTING IN UVALDE FIVE MINUTES
EARLIER THAN PREVIOUSLY KNOWN.
CNN'S ROSA FLORES LIVE IN SAN
ANTONIO WITH THE LATEST ON THIS.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE, ROSA?
>> Reporter: WELL, YOU KNOW,
JOHN, THIS IS SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE UNTIL NOW TEXAS DPS HAS
REALLY JUST POINTED THE FINGER
AT THE LOCALS SAYING THAT THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE WAS AN
ABJECT FAILURE.
SO LET ME TAKE YOU THROUGH THIS,
BECAUSE ACCORDING TO THE
TIMELINES RELEASED BY TEXAS DPS
AND TESTIMONY BY COLONEL McCRAW,
THE SHOOTER ENTERED THAT SCHOOL
AT 11:33 A.M.
AND THAT THE FIRST TEXAS DPS
TROOPER ENTERED THE HALLWAY AT
11:42, THAT'S NINE MINUTES AFTER
THAT SHOOTER ENTERED.
WELL, THIS NEW BODY CAMERA
FOOTAGE, WHAT IT SHOWS IS AN
OFFICER WALKING TOWARDS THE WEST
ENTRANCE, THAT'S THE SAME
ENTRANCE THAT THE SHOOTER
ENTERED, AND THERE IS A TEXAS
DPS OFFICER, AND THE TIME CODE
IS 11:37:51 THAT MORNING.
THAT'S FOUR MINUTES AND 51
SECONDS AFTER THE SHOOTER
ENTERED AND THAT TROOPER WAS
ALREADY THERE.
IT IS UNCLEAR EXACTLY WHEN HE
ACTUALLY ARRIVED ON SCENE, BUT I
DID GO BACK TO THE TESTIMONY BY
COLONEL McCRAW THAT HE GAVE THE
SENATE LAST MONTH AND HE STATED
THAT THAT PARTICULAR TROOPER
DROVE THE SCHOOL POLICE OFFICER
THAT WAS PART OF THE INITIAL
RESPONSE AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SURVEILLANCE VIDEO, THAT SCHOOL
POLICE OFFICER FIRST COMES INTO
THAT SURVEILLANCE HALLWAY VIDEO
AT 11:36:18.
SO CLEARLY THEY'RE A LOT EARLIER
THAN WE HAD PREVIOUSLY KNOWN.
AND WE ASKED TEXAS DPS ABOUT
THIS AND HERE IS WHAT THEY SAID.
THEY SENT US A STATEMENT SAYING,
THE DIRECTOR'S TESTIMONY IS
ACCURATE REGARDING WHAT DPS
PERSONNEL ENTERED THAT HALLWAY
AND WHEN THEY ENTERED.
OUR INTERNAL COMMITTEE IS
CURRENTLY REVIEWING WHETHER OR
NOT THOSE INDIVIDUALS VIOLATED
ANY DEPARTMENT POLICIES OR
DOCTRINE.
AND IN THIS STRONGEST STATEMENT
RELEASED YET TO CNN, THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY, THE D.A.
TELLING CNN THAT -- THAT SHE
WILL NOT HESITATE TO INDICT, TO
CRIMINALLY CHARGE ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IF THE LAW
ALLOWS.
SO BEING VERY CLEAR THERE, JOHN,
BUT SHE IS ALSO BEING VERY
FORCEFUL SAYING SHE'S NOT GOING
TO HESITATE TO CRIMINALLY CHARGE
ANYONE IF THE LAW ALLOWS HER TO
DO SO.
JOHN?
>> AT THIS STAGE, THEY SHOULD BE
SPLITTING HAIRS OR PARSING
LANGUAGE ABOUT WHO SHOWED UP
WHEN.
THIS SHOULD BE A TIMELINE THAT
SHOULD BE CLEAR TO EVERYONE.
ROSA FLORES, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR CONTINUED REPORTING.
KEEP ON PRESSING.